I hate to bring you down but Australia
out of the World Cup and I'm just
curious how you feel about that does
that bother you
interesting that you if you think it
would affect our self-esteem but
actually now we're pretty excited wait
Australia is excited to be out of the
World Cup I can't excuse it but we seem
to just be really happy to have gotten
there it's quite bizarre once a more
relaxing approach to the World Cup i
suggest following a country like
Australia it's almost like you know we
didn't get invited to the wedding
right witting invited to the engagement
party we just were there when someone
announced they got engaged and we were
quite happy about it these other
countries freaked out I mean they're
devastated when they get kicked out but
it is true Australians are just happy
they're happy people we're happy we have
you know my favorite sport Australian
rules football we have an award
mediocrity like you get a goal for
kicking the ball between the two big
sticks but you get a point for missing
and going either side really it just
just really likes a reward effort it'd
be like a basketball if someone had had
a shot missed all together just bounced
off the backboard and hit him in the
head would go that's just a point right
there that's just garden scoring yeah
try miss the backboard half a point yeah
good you still get those kid trophies
where everybody's a winner now you
started out in stand-up and you actually
I never realized this until today we
found that you had a comedy album I did
we're going back a long way I'm scared
okay no we found the cover of your
comedy album and there you are
[Laughter]
there you are so you're not a shy guy at
all more than happy to to to show your
your backside it's it's what you do when
you're not flying mr. Conan that you do
that stuff and you don't think it's
gonna come back to bite you on the ass
but you know you're not you're not
afraid to show your backside or ass
whatever you wanted
you're not afraid to show your butt in a
movie you've done a lot of work and TV
shows movies where you've you've shown
you about that's not true I I'm done
with it I actually retired my ass a few
years ago really so you you have in the
past shown your butt a lot but now
you're retiring it I retired that you
didn't hear those like a press
conference never turned up surprisingly
but it was about 2010 I just woke up one
day and I said the bats darkness it's
had an office your butt getting on a
boat and sailing off you you decided no
matter what okay you've retired you've
retired you're but yes over what if
Martin Scorsese called you up and said I
want you to star in a movie greatest
role of a lifetime it's gonna win ten
Oscars but you have to show your but
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen
let me put it this way it's it's the
parental purposes you got kids right yes
I mean you can't walk on to the school
grounds and hold your head up high
having just drop your pants at work you
just can't it's just so it's really it's
actually retired for parental purposes
that's very mature of you it is I think
it is I think I do I do think it's very
mature of you
and III heard that you had possibly
retired your butt so we decided we put
together a montage to sort of say
to your butt for all time let's take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
we had the special lens on the camera
and everything we were ready to go in
case you pat that's it that's a second
retirement that that's it that's it okay
you